nous sommes en avril 2016 à la clinique
saint-vincent le docteur peschier
s'apprête à anesthésier une de ses
collègues le docteur nambot ils se
connaissent depuis dix ans le compagnon
de madame non beau anesthésistes
intervient il veut endormir lui-même son
ami et bouleverse l'ordre des opérations
la perfusion prévu pour madame non bo
est administré à une autre patiente qui
décédera d'un arrêt cardiaque
le docteur peschier at il voulu
supprimer sa collègue
ma cliente n'est pas seul à penser le
docteur péché a tenté de l'empoisonner
les enquêteurs sont aussi persuadés que
le docteur péché a voulu empoisonner ma
cliente s'était elle sa cible clairement
les enquêteurs en sont persuadés les
interventions du docteur peschier ces
empoisonnements présumé coïncide avec
des coups de froid avec le couple
lambeaux série deux collègues envisagées
comme des concurrents monsieur peschier
faisait preuve d'un ego surdimensionné
et en l'occurrence il n'est pas faux de
dire que il n'hésitait pas se considérer
comme le meilleur anesthésiste de la
clinique avec un certain mépris pour ses
autres confrères donc tout ceci a
entraîné un dérapage
laurence nico avait 50 ans elle était en
bonne santé c'est elle qui est décédé
son compagnon s'exprime pour la première
fois il se pose des questions sur le dr
serrie pourquoi a t'il inverser l'ordre
des opérations c'est le rendre car payer
pour eux pour moi je pense que c'est riz
ou les pâtes sa femme tfz ils devaient
le savoir ce qui se passe et d'égaler
les mois ou les années qui s'est passé
avec les autres victimes qui sont
reconnus aujourd'hui ils parlent pas et
guy rien
la défense du docteur pesci et dénonce
une manoeuvre déloyale et rappelle que
cette tentative de meurtre présumé n'a
pas été retenue par la justice
la justice n'a jamais reproché au dr
peschier d'avoir voulu tuer madame
lambeaux cette théorie est ridicule il
ne suffit pas de créer un coupable idéal
par tous les moyens pour qu'ils le
soient le docteur peschier est innocent
ces révélations changeront-elles la
donne selon une source judiciaire le 12
juin prochain la chambre de
l'instruction doit réexaminer le cas du
docteur peschier qui pour l'instant est
placé sous contrôle judiciaire